I used to do that sometime I'd have
chicks come over this was one of our
moves with ladies first you have a lady
come over right and look you meet her
outside but make sure all the doors are
open make sure your face is well-lit
don't be that crazy - meeting a lady by
a dark tree or some kind of [ __ ] like
that it's not safe so you meet a lady
you maybe meet her out front but meter
you know where she could see your face
don't take a candle out there by your
face that [ __ ] is old school you know
this ain't Abraham Lincoln dating this
is New Age dating so you just want to be
in an area that's NAT that's lit either
naturally or lit by some type of street
lamps or porch light but you meet the
lady outside let her know you're safe so
then you have the lady come over right
and you have a you put on a little movie
something something set something kind
of something that shows that you're cool
with ladies a league of their own
that's about ladies um playing baseball
and you know some of them not really
experimenting with lesbian but no it's
not like that it's more ladies playing
baseball and wanting to hold down the
fort while their husbands are away
defending their country so that's a
great movie and and I'll turn the bass
up a lot of a lot of people don't think
this if you got some speakers at the
house or if you got car speakers but you
don't have a car right now because you
[ __ ] up on payments or whatever then
get your [ __ ] get your speakers put them
in the house and you know get a couple
12s or some 20s or whatever and turn the
bass up you put a league of their own on
with that bass up man you start and
you're gonna unleash a real [ __ ] fever
in the air because there's you a league
of their own that's the movie lets a
woman know you safe another movie you
could watch as a movie called up it's
about two grandparents and one of them
dies and one of them his house is almost
almost getting repossessed by balloons
and it's I guess it's like a it's like a
way that Disney or whatever Pixar kind
of shows you how a mortgage can work you
got balloon payments you know deal with
the your house gets taken away
but what it is is you can play you can
play that and put the bass up cuz bass
that's foreplay that's electronic
equipment doing foreplay for you you
know cuz we don't know you don't always
have a lot of time to touch your lady
right so you need to use sonic abilities
like um like bass like bass cuz that
thing that's that's feeling on it you
know you get the vibrations going that's
touching your lady everywhere a little
bit lightly and next thing you know her
nipples of stimulation
you know full-body if she has body hair
standing on end and that's you know and
then a lot of the activity she's alert
she got body alertness she has body
alertness and she has heart
trustworthiness because you're watching
up or you're watching league of their
own you got that base turned up and that
[ __ ] is savage man and that's a good way
to meet a lady and you know get a lot of
the that way you're getting free you
know you're getting a lot of free
sensuality occurring in the room because
you got a sexy movie on something that
sentimental shows your supportive of
women and at the same time you got the
bass turned up you know and that's
that's creating a sensuality to a sexual
environment you know that's creating
that that caveman doodoo there's a
little crook there's no crying in
baseball ball ball ball [ __ ] hire a DJ
remix that [ __ ] boy you know what still
well still well live your life you can
do it and that's a great way to all have
a date with a lady right there good
evening good afternoon and other times
thanks for watching that video you just
saw I mean it was okay but the next
video you can watch could be way better
what if you watch a video right now that
changes your life well you could watch
this one or watch this one watch this
one watch this one watch this one